Edgar is in Rochester New York hi Edgar
how are you I'm doing ok how are you
days better than I deserve what's up
well I got this car lease I got into 2
years ago it was over my budget but it
was the impulse thing I just wanted the
car but now I make about 29 29 grand a
year
I work as a patient care technician in
hospital mm-hm and I if I do overtime I
make up to 40,000 good so I got 20 more
payments left but I want to get out of
this car lease and I want to be able to
save more money every month and I'm
having a hard time seeing some extra
dollars right here yeah so how much a
month as the car leaves I make three I
get about its 359 dollars a month okay
and have you asked them for the early
buyout amount on the lease what you owe
today to pay it off and get the title it
was about sixteen thousand four hundred
and ninety four dollars when did you get
that figure it was it was about about
two months ago okay and that's what it
takes to buy the title two months ago
yes okay that's not the remaining number
of payments yeah that was the number
that they gave me when I when I called
him about the buyout okay all right have
you looked up what the car is worth it's
it's worth between thirteen and fifteen
thousand dollars on Kelley Blue Book
okay so let's pretend that you sold it
for fifteen thousand and the early bio
to 16,000 that leaves you one thousand
dollars in the hole right correct so
you'd have to have the thousand dollars
to be able to pay the difference because
if I bring you a check and I'm the buyer
for fifteen you got to be able to get me
the title and in order to do that you
got to put another thousand with my 15
check to get to up to sixteen to pay it
off you fall on me
yes yeah so we got to determine the
difference between what you sell it for
and what the early buyout is you have to
have
Mountain Dew of any money saved I have a
$4,100 in the bank you're in business we
can do this okay so let's let's do a
fresh call on what the payoff is the
early buyout and let's do a fresh look
on Kelly Blue Book on what the car is
worth and let's put the car up for sale
and be prepared to write a check for the
difference and get it sold if you keep
it 20 more months that's seven thousand
dollars out of pocket I'd rather you be
one or two thousand out of pocket than
seven so let's dump this thing okay is
this making sense yeah okay and then
you're gonna have a couple thousand
bucks left over of your savings because
it's probably only going to be one or
two maybe three out of pocket whatever
you got left in savings is what you pay
cash for a new car
oh it's not new though by the way right
it's a two thousand dollar car but guess
what Edgar has no car payments anymore
in our talk here and then when Edgar's
got no car payments you're used to say
you're used to spending three hundred
fifty bucks a month in ten months
that's thirty five hundred dollars so
you can move up in car pretty quick just
pay yourself a car payment right yeah
yeah and this gets you back up out of it
I don't want you to driving $1,000 or
$2,000 a car very long but we'll do that
for a little while if it gets you out of
this bear trap you stuck your foot in
yeah so so did you how old are you I'm
29 years old okay what kind of car was
this it's a 2016 Jeep Patriot
oh nice car yeah okay so yeah
everybody's got to do not everybody but
most of us have to do at least one
really stupid car deal in our life the
good news is you've got yours out of the
way next time you go on a car dealer a
lot it's to deliver so you're not going
over there and getting fleeced again are
you
nope yeah you learned your lesson you're
good man thanks for calling I'm proud of
you keep it up brother it's like federal
law in your 20s I mean it's like federal
somewhere there's a law passed somewhere
in your 20s you have to completely lose
your mom
we guys know women do it but they blame
it on the children I have to have a safe
car for my children it needs an airbag
that's not your mother
you know it's like oh wait
the guys want a car just because we want
a car we want something with a muffler
you know why I still don't understand
why guys buy Tesla I wouldn't need like
an app or something that made a noise
like it needs to make a noise how could
it be a car if it doesn't make a noise
man all my cars got loud mufflers I'm a
redneck this is the Dave Ramsey show